[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity
part 8 summary and applications
to conclude this series of videos we
will summarize all the concepts by
proposing a catalogue of the different
possible solutions
and applying them in several concrete
examples
we'll be able to calculate the time
dilation for an astronaut in the space
station
determine the equations that govern the
motion of an object falling towards the
sun
and even explain the behavior of light
around the black hole
[Music]
to begin with let's summarize together
the different steps that allow us to
solve a problem
in general relativity
the first step is to determine the space
time geometry in which we want to solve
our problem
this means choosing the metric that we
want to use
in an empty universe we will use the
minkowski metric
the flat space time of special
relativity
around a spherical and static mass we
will use the schwarzschild metric
this metric is the most practical
because it is simple
but can still model many different
situations
it can describe a planet a star or even
a static black hole
there is also a range of other more
exotic metrics
such as the flrw metric which describes
a homogeneous universe
the morris thorne metric describing a
non-gravitating wormhole
or the ker metric which accounts for the
rotation of a black hole on itself
the second step is to choose the
coordinates that we will use to describe
our problem
depending on the situation some
coordinates are more appropriate than
others
the minkowski metric is most often
expressed with cartesian coordinates
which reflect its linear structure
for the schwarzschild metric we choose
spherical coordinates
to exploit the symmetry of the central
mass
that said our problem may not correspond
to any of these usual solutions
and in this case we will have to
determine the most appropriate
coordinates
start directly from the einstein
equation and integrate the different
curvature tensors
to find an expression for the metric
tensor
this process turns out to be extremely
complex
and usually requires approximations and
computer simulations
once our coordinates have been chosen
the third step is to analyze the
symmetries of our problem
to reduce its number of dimensions for
example
to describe the motion of an apple
falling vertically
we only need one dimension of space
along a single axis
likewise for an object in orbit around a
spherical mass
symmetry tells us that its trajectory is
confined within a plane
the object has no reason to leave this
plane on one side or the other
in this situation we can align our
coordinates with this plane
reducing the problem to two dimensions
of space
finally once we've chosen a metric and
coordinates
we can seek to find the solution of our
problem
for solving the problem we have two
possibilities
on the one hand we may want to find the
components of the velocity of an object
through space-time
for example we may want to express the
temporal component
the rate at which our time passes
compared to its proper time
in this case we use the fact that all
objects in the universe
move at the speed of light the norm of
the velocity vector
must always be equal to c which gives us
an equation relating the components of
the velocity
to each other
on the other hand we may want to
determine how these components change
over time
in other words how the object
accelerates through our coordinates
this way we can describe whole
trajectories through space-time
for example we might want to determine
the motion of an apple falling towards
earth
or the trajectory of the earth around
the sun
in this case it is necessary to
calculate the christopher symbols
allowing us to use the geodesic equation
in the case of the apple for example the
equation tells us that its altitude
coordinate
undergoes a negative acceleration it
falls
[Music]
to sum up we start by choosing a
space-time geometry
to describe our universe
then we reduce the number of dimensions
using the symmetries of our problem
and finally we use either the norm of
the velocity
to relate its different components
or the geodesic equation to determine
the trajectory of an object
with this method we will be able to
solve a large number of physical
problems
step by step
example one time dilation
in this first example we want to
determine the time dilation
for an astronaut in the space station
to solve this problem we will follow the
different steps that we described
previously
first let's choose the metric that best
fits
our situation we can consider that the
earth is a sphere
and we can neglect its rotation on
itself which is very slow
against the speed of light in this
simplified framework
space-time outside the planet can be
modeled by the schwarzschild metric
in its most intuitive form the
schwarzschild metric
is expressed with spherical coordinates
measured from infinity
we imagine observing the planet from a
great distance
and measuring the time t on our clock
the altitude r of the station from the
center of the earth
and the angles theta and phi
the metric tensor then takes the
following form
[Music]
once the metric tensor is expressed in
all four dimensions
we can try to reduce it taking advantage
of the symmetries of the problem
to simplify we can assume that the
station follows a circle around the
earth
aligning our coordinates on this circle
we no longer need the angle theta
because the station orbits in a plane
and neither do we need the altitude
r which remains constant along the
circle
we can thus get rid of the rows and the
columns that correspond to these two
coordinates
the position of the astronaut in space
time can be described with only two
numbers
the time t and the angle phi
finally once the metric tensor is
expressed in a coordinate system
we can move on to solving the problem
the time dilation that we want to
calculate corresponds to the ratio
between the rate of our time t
and the astronaut's proper time in other
words
it's the temporal component of its
velocity
the rate at which the coordinate t
increases as proper time
goes by
to determine this temporal component we
will use the norm of the velocity vector
in space-time all objects move at the
speed of light
the astronaut moves both in time and
space
but his overall speed and space time is
always
equal to c
the norm of a vector in general
relativity is obtained using the metric
tensor
the generalized version of the
pythagorean theorem
expanding the sum and using the
schwarzschild metric
we obtain an equation which directly
relates the two components of the
velocity
on the one hand the angular velocity the
rate at which the angle that the
astronaut
forms increases around the earth
and on the other hand the temporal
velocity that we want to determine
rearranging the terms and using the fact
that the orbital velocity of the station
is equal to its angular velocity
multiplied by its altitude we finally
obtain the expression for the time
dilation that the astronaut undergoes
compared to a distant observer
for the international space station we
estimate a dilation of
one nanosecond for each second of proper
time
the astronauts time passes slightly
slower than that of the far away
observer
example 2 a vertical fool
in this second example we want to
describe the fall of a satellite towards
the sun
we consider a vertical fool and we make
the approximation that the sun is
spherical
and static and can therefore be
described by the schwarzschild metric
we will use the same coordinates as in
the previous case
we observe from a very far distance and
measure the time t
on our clock the altitude r between the
satellite and the center of the sun
and the angles theta and phi
as the fall is vertical the angles theta
and phi
do not vary and we can already get rid
of them
the position of the satellite depends
only on its altitude
and time
in this example we will not be
interested in the velocity of the
satellite
but its evolution we want to determine
the acceleration of its coordinates
to do this we start by calculating the
christopher symbols
in the schwarzschild metric with these
coordinates the christopher symbols take
the following form
once calculated we can inject them into
the geodesic equation
the geodesic equation gives us two
relations
it tells us the acceleration of each
coordinate describing the satellite
on the one hand its temporal
acceleration
and on the other hand the acceleration
of its altitude
these two formulas allow us to integrate
the trajectory of the satellite with
respect to proper time
as long as we know its initial velocity
we can calculate its acceleration
and thus the way in which the vector
will change at the next instant
to go further it is possible to
interpret these equations
in a more elegant way the first equation
in particular can be put in a different
form which indicates the conservation of
a certain quantity
this quantity is proportional to what we
call energy
in the schwarzschild metric the energy
of an object
depends on its altitude and its movement
through time
example three array of lights
to conclude this series of videos we
will describe together the trajectory of
a light ray
around a black hole
in the case of a static black hole
space-time is once again described by
the schwarzschild metric
in general relativity light is a very
special case
which we have to treat differently to
understand why
let's go back to the fundamentals
we saw in the previous videos that an
object traces a world line through space
time
this world line can be graduated with
intervals of equal length
these intervals along the curve allow us
to interpret it as a movement
this is called proper time
as proper time goes by the object moves
through space time
and we can define a space-time velocity
vector
but unlike mata light does not travel
any distance
through space time two points along its
world line are always separated
by a distance of zero therefore
we cannot define a proper time for light
we need to be more careful when dealing
with light because it's not possible to
define a proper velocity vector for it
to solve this problem we have to define
a new graduation
specific to this light ray
this new graduation is called an affine
parameter
unlike proper time the affine parameter
has no real physical meaning
it does not measure any distance in
space time
it is simply an arbitrary graduation
which will serve as a mathematical tool
for equations
thanks to this affine parameter we can
define a sort of velocity vector
and thus use the geodesic equation which
remains valid
on the other hand we will also be able
to use the norm of this vector
but unlike a real velocity vector this
artificial vector that we have created
especially for the light ray
has zero length as light travels no
distance its norm
is zero
being careful to account for this
difference we can still apply the same
reasoning as before
and obtain the geodesic equations which
govern the path of light rays
along their affine parameter around a
black hole
these equations tell us that light is
deflected around the black hole
which acts like a gravitational lens
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you